I once went to the medieval Torture
Museum in Prague
and uh
you know just the ways that people have
one of those like the Cozy coffins with
the spikes yeah the Iron Maiden for that
that's what I mean there was a the thing
that I was not anticipating excited
that's an Iron Man the thing that I was
not anticipating was the number of
um
heavy metal ways that they would lower
people onto metal spikes for whatever
you know whatever the the crime was
depending on what orifice
we'd lowered though not mortal combated
not light hit and dropped on spikes but
lowered slowly they would lower you ask
for this on one of them the lower your
ass first
that I don't care for that to a metal
Spike also the guy that suggested that
little glimpse into what he's he's about
like you're sorry I listened to your
album on the way down it's fantastic oh
thank you your new album I should say uh
human overboard yeah I got nervous I was
gonna get it wrong
well you got it right that there's that
great line in the first track I believe
which is like I think that says more
about you yeah which is a great which is
great that's like good poetry good music
but like the guy that's like or we tie
him up to his butt and then they're like
losing his butt and it's like Steve
everything you have is bad it doesn't
have to be the butt does it have to be
the butt and then they end up using
these I mean it's not uncommon that
it the little plaque at the end would be
like and the creator of this was so and
so and this was used to kill him at the
end of his often really multiple times
that's like because think about it if
you are going to torture and murder
someone who happens to be the inventor
of a torture and murdering machine
why not use the thing that they made I
mean he's only gonna have notes if you
use something else they're lowering the
face versus like guys this would be a
lot scarier if it was my butt first
because I can see it coming right but
first you don't know
yeah and then it's over
[Music]